- Funny you should mention Zack, Ned.
(laughing)
- Ohhhh!
- You'd probably have
great sex with his wife.
(all laughing)
- Yeah!
(elated music)
- So the Try Guys have a
new show called Squad Wars,
where celebrity squads face
off against each other.
- We just kind of assume
that we're a good squad,
we never actually proved it.
- So we're gonna take a
genetic compatibility test--
- To see if we actually
truly are the ultimate squad.
I can say with confidence that we are not.
I don't need to spit in
a vial to find that out.
(upbeat music)
- We look at
your genetic composition,
and how it affects your neurochemistry.
And then we can actually predict
who's gonna be a good love relationship,
who's gonna be a good bromance,
because we look at your genes.
- Are we gonna find out if
Zack and I are close friends,
or if maybe Eugene and I should have sex?
What do we find out here?
- Yeah, I could tell you those things.
(all laughing)
- Wow!
- We had geneticists
look under a microscope
so we could figure out
your brain chemistry.
We look at genes like oxytocin, dopamine,
and we give a psychological
profile test as well,
because relationships aren't just
about your pure, neurochemistry.
You're born a certain way biologically,
but then you're raised a certain way,
that also shapes your personality.
So Instant Chemistry
needs two things from you.
First, we need you to take a
very detailed psychological test.
- Alright, time to take a test
to find out who's actually my friend.
- So these are questions of
if you're in a relationship.
- I'm gonna answer them,
thinking about my wife,
which would just be great.
- You are sitting together with
your partner watching a movie on TV.
You enjoy reaching out and touching,
whoa really getting into this quick.
- Obviously, almost certain, yes!
- Zack's one fellow that loves to cuddle.
- Absolutely, we're hanging out, touching.
- You get sweaty, you get tangled,
your arm falls asleep, I'll say possibly.
- You and your partner
have taken a long weekend
together at a nearby resort.
- Guess we're rich now.
- You promptly step up and
speak to the management
in an effort to upgrade.
- I would love for somebody
else to handle confrontation.
- Yeah, but it's a resort, you pay money.
Almost certainly, yeah.
- You're not doing it right,
if you're not getting free stuff.
- Possibly.
- I'm done!
(trumpet blaring)
- View the results of my
psychological profile.
- One of the things we looked at is
who is more of an alpha male,
and who is more of a submissive?
Two alpha males don't do well together.
They're competing with each other so much,
and they don't get stuff done.
If I had to ask the four of you
to pick just one person who you think
would be your best friend,
if you were stuck on a
desert island for a weekend,
who would it be with?
- Ned won't cooperate with me,
but together we will
get the most stuff done.
Keith would get along the nicest.
- Okay, interesting, and
who would you choose?
- Yeah, I would also choose Keith.
Zack would find, like, issues,
I would get so (laughing) frustrated.
- So what I'm going to reveal to you,
(all laughing)
Eugene and Ned come out
the highest alpha males.
(air whooshing)
And Keith and Zack come out as submissive.
Generally, submissive males get along
with alphas very very well.
Eugene, even though you said,
that if you were stuck on a desert island,
it was Ned that you'd want to be with,
the truth is you guys wouldn't survive
cause you'd get nothing done.
Another part of the
psychology test is intimacy.
You need to be open, honest,
and vulnerable, right?
So, what I found is, three of you
are really predisposed to be able
to have intimacy very easily,
(all laughing)
emotional intimacy.
- [Zack] I wonder who
that fourth person is.
- (laughing) Who do you think that fourth
could be, who's a little more reserved?
Ah, what I learned about
your psychological profile
is you actually really crave closeness,
and you desire intimacy,
but you're really reserved
and afraid to open up.
- No, no, nooo.
(laughing)
- Eugene, I never knew.
(all talking at once)
- You just want us to love you.
- Three of you are also, really
completely social animals.
You love social activity,
you love social interactions.
You're open, you're out there,
you wanna engage with other people.
One of you is a little like that,
but really really values time alone.
- I like one day where I
don't have to talk to people.
- I hate being alone.
- I also don't like being alone.
- It actually came out Eugene,
(air whooshing)
so, social to a point, but really value
your alone time, it really matters.
- Zack, maybe you're just
alone on Sundays by default.
(all laughing)
The other thing we look at when we look
at you psychologically, is we look at
your ability to be social,
and care about each other's
feelings as you're doing stuff.
And, again, three of you
highly value cooperation
and social harmony but,
one of you,
kinda forceful and aggressive,
(all laughing)
desires not to please other people,
but prefers to lead,
(all laughing)
and not afraid of confrontation.
- It's the same guy.
- You're wrong.
- Oh really?
- It's Ned.
(cheering and laughing)
- You said "I think I'd prefer him
on the desert island,
except he'd frustrate me too much", right?
- Oh.
- So you're not caring
too much--
- Yeah it's your problem.
- About people's feelings,
cause you're so frustrated,
and you just wanna lead and go forward.
- Oh no.
- Whereas the others
are more concerned with social harmony.
So even if their idea
is not the best way--
- Oh yeah, oh yeah!
- They might take it.
- If it's not the best
idea, why are we doing it?
- Exactly.
- You have a new color
of red in your face.
(laughing)
- We are just having
the best of times, what's next?
- Let's start to look
at your neurochemistry
from a biological level.
We need you to spit into a test tube.
- We're going to spit in a tube.
- For science.
- This is a lot of instructions
for spitting in a tube.
- For collection of human DNA.
Is this going to the government?
- As a scientist, shit.
(throat clearing)
Please look away.
- Okay, so I'm gonna spit,
until it gets to this line.
- I missed with my liquid.
Seems to be a recurring theme for me.
- Did I give too much?
- Oof, now that's way too much.
- [Cameraman] Keith, no!
- I was just gonna take
a little of it back.
- Apparently I have a very wet mouth.
- Put this in until it clicks real loud.
(lid clicking)
- We're in.
- It just added the
science liquid to my spit.
It's blue now.
- I wonder what this is?
- And now I shake it for five seconds.
One,
Two.
- Shake the spit.
- [Zack] Three.
- [Zack] Four, five.
Smells like science.
- Now we're gonna send it off to a lab,
and see who we're the
most compatible with.
- First gene we look at is oxytocin,
the bonding hormone.
We're looking at who's a thinker,
and who's a listener.
What listeners are really good
at, is interpreting emotions.
Whereas the thinkers are
better at decisive action.
- Just charge into the
breach, don't give a fuck.
- And we found out that
two of you are thinkers,
and two of you are listeners.
Ned, and Keith, the thinkers.
(air whooshing)
Eugene and Zack, the listeners.
- Makes sense.
- And Eugene and Zack
probably think that these
guys aren't listening to you.
- We think we're good listeners,
but we're actually not?
- No, you are actually listening to them.
- No, we are listening,
it's just we've heard
your argument for the last
hour and we're tired of it.
- Exactly!
- Lot of emotions,
I'm very conflicted.
I just wanna find love here.
- So, the next gene we wanna look at,
is the dopamine receptor D4,
and it has to do with
motivation, attention,
learning, and I found
something really interesting
in your guys's genetic profile here.
The 7R+ gene only makes up less
than 30% of the population.
Highly represented in CEOs
and high-ranking executives.
Uh, Ned, Keith and Zack,
all have the Explorer 7R+ dopamine gene.
- We're rare?
- [Dr. Wendy] You're rare!
- We're the minority?
(all laughing)
- That's not cause we're white,
straight males, though, right?
- No, we didn't look at
the genes surrounding race.
- We're a minority!
- Crazy.
- White, straight men being CEOs, crazy.
- I think you're a good
balance to all of them
because it makes you very judicious,
and very prudent, and more careful.
These guys are gonna more
likely charge forward,
and you're gonna go "whoa whoa whoa,
we'll get killed doing that".
- [Keith] You are always the
person right before we shoot
to be like "is this the
best way we could do this?"
- Because you're surrounded
by another alpha male,
actually Ned, that's making
you a little more dominant
than you normally would,
or that's normally more
comfortable to you.
You know, because genetically,
that's not how you're wired.
- Grew up with two alpha sisters,
and I was always the judicious one.
- Sometimes, you run with
the dogs you might get bit.
(cheering)
(laughing)
- We also looked at another
kind of dopamine gene.
We look at the warrior, the fighter right?
Versus the worrier.
So the warrior tends to
be highly highly creative,
but really lousy at multitasking.
The worrier, a hard time
dealing with anxiety,
and gets more pleasure out of life.
So where do you think you guys land?
- Gosh, I think I'm really creative,
and I worry all the time.
- Generally, when I work on a project,
nothing else matters.
- Warrior sounds cooler,
so certainly we all wanna be that one.
- Worriers have more enjoyment in life.
- [Eugene] Are we evenly
divided, two and two?
- [Zack] It's two and two?
- You all have the same.
(gasps)
- Are we all fighters?
- I think we're all fighters.
- You're all warriors.
- [All] Yeah!
- [Dr. Wendy] You guys are
all lousy, lousy multitaskers.
- That's why we have four Try Guys.
(laughing)
- The next gene,
is my absolute favorite.
This test can actually
predict hot passionate sex
that will last a really long time.
So, listen to this, back in
our anthropological past,
when you were out mating
in the environment,
you wanted to find somebody who had
a very different immune system than you,
because, when two people mate,
they might take brown eyes from one,
long legs from another,
poorer eyesight from one, et cetera.
(laughing)
Except immune systems.
They actually combine, and
make a stronger human being.
There's been some research in same-sex
platonic friendships that show
that you want immune
systems to be similar.
So you smell like each other's brothers!
- Yeah, that'd be distracting
if I'm always trying to fuck Zack.
- [Dr. Wendy] Yeah it would be.
- Yes, it would be, Ned.
- Um, funny you should mention Zack, Ned.
(gasps)
- Ohhh!
(laughing)
You have an 80% similarity
in your immune systems.
(air whooshing)
- [Ned] Ohh, so we're brothers!
- So your wife would probably
be super attracted to me.
(record scratching)
- [Dr. Wendy] Exactly!
(laughing)
At least for sex, yes.
You'd probably have
great sex with his wife.
(laughing)
- [Zack] Yeah!
- [Dr. Wendy] So if it's about hot sex,
I wanna choose the most disparate
or different immune systems,
and that would be Eugene and Keith.
(air whooshing)
- So we would fuck
each other like hard?
There is a lot of sexual tension here.
He denies it, that's only the more proof.
- Looking at all of the genes,
looking at your psychological test,
I can tell you who the
most compatible are,
and who the absolute least compatible are.
Least compatible are, not surprisingly,
sitting the furthest away from
each other, Ned and Eugene.
(air whooshing)
- [Together] No!
- Is it cause we're both too dominant?
- Yes, and your
relationship could actually
benefit from the two of you softening
your need for dominance.
- [All] Aww.
- Sometimes, like--
- Shut the fuck up.
(laughing)
- There are two people here,
who are most compatible.
- [Keith] I think I'm the
most compatible with Zack.
- [Zack] Keith and I are actually in love.
- [Eugene] Keith and I are most compatible
when it comes to sociability.
- [Ned] Zack's kinda my boy though.
- [Zack] What a good guy Ned is.
- [Eugene] Zack and I have
already given up on humanity.
- [Keith] I'd fuck the hell outta Ned.
- The most compatible couple here,
could have a long, long,
healthy, happy relationship.
And we can predict, with
more than 80% reliability,
that you'll be friends for
years and years and years.
Ned and Zack.
- [Ned] Ohh!
Me and Zack, ohh Zack!
- The degree of compatibility
we see psychologically
we only see, usually, in really
long-term married couples.
- We could be married!
(laughing)
- No!
I'm Ned's wife now.
- I guess I'm right, I am
the dead body on the island.
- You're the one that keeps us together.
- You don't have an
extreme to make it a match
with anybody, you just
get along with everybody.
- (whispering) They all
think I'm their best friend.
- Biology is not destiny,
neither is psychology.
It is the interaction of both,
and remember, our biggest environment
that affects our biology,
are our close relationships.
- So you're saying,
even though the genetics
tell us we should be
compatible with one person,
we can choose to all be friends anyway.
- Don't try and force
me out of that solution.
(all laughing)
(elated music)
- Hey, thanks for watching this video.
If you like this and are hungry for more,
check out Squad Wars, you can
get it for 30 days for free!
This week, Ned and I
join up with two squads
to become professional wrestlers.
And, we almost die.
- All I learned today is that Zack
secretly wants Ned's wife.
- What is going on here?
(laughing)
- That wasn't the takeaway from me.